what are some things you learned in the
last five years that you wish you knew
in the first five years that you've
moved here some of the places and some
things I've already said but number one
is the bank in yourself if you really
believe in yourself you have to Bank in
yourself and what that means is you
can't depend on an external person to
make your dreams happen if you want to
make them happen you go make them happen
yourself now actors some actors are very
much independent of a studio or a
filmmaker if you're not a filmmaker
yourself but even an actor in a way you
could find the right director you could
find money people you could then produce
and put a whole project together but
it's the bank in yourself it's to start
learning and figure out what you need to
do and do it do it yourself we've Wally
watt wasted we done completely outside
of the studio system and it would have
never got made if I was I'd still be
scratching my head handing in
descriptive people and even though
people love the script I still be
handing it to people and even the people
that might have want to make it they
weren't gonna make me the director who
are you so I had to do it to learn and
to prove myself you know that's another
thing that I've learned is people like I
said people don't see potential you have
to show them there I I'm the same person
I was five or six years ago when I was
telling people you know I'm gonna be a
film director they don't really believe
me they don't really know there's so
many people that say things in this town
now they treat me with totally different
respect and they look at me like a
filmmakers so it's very interesting in
that way it's like you know what you're
going to do or what you're capable of so
go do it and show people don't don't
trust that they see it - they're not
gonna see it you have to show them what
would you say to people though that
aren't as confident with themselves
maybe they're not confident with the way
they look I mean you're handsome man
you're tall you present yourself well so
it's easy for me to see why people aside
from talent would want to believe in you
but not everybody has that so what would
you say to people that don't feel like
they have it it's funny though because
I'm motivated but that kind of goes into
your motivation
motivated by people not believing me in
a way I mean I have a lot of support and
a lot of my father and my mother and my
family believe in me a lot but I'm
actually more motivated by people to
tell me I can't do something and I don't
know I don't know how healthy that is
but that's what it is and I think I
think ultimately if you're not you have
to start looking at yourself yeah then
the start of the work doesn't start with
with making films the work starts in ER
and then you need to go look at yourself
analyze yourself and really build
yourself up maybe with positive
reinforcement every morning we met it
may be meditation whatever it is build
yourself up to believe the belief that
you can do it because without the belief
I mean you're not gonna do it you know
if you believe what people tell you you
know I think everybody who's ever done
anything amazing they were told they
can't do it and if they believed that
they would never would have done it so
you know the fact that it's never been
done before just makes me excited that
you know I'll be the first you know how
you know so it's more challenge when
someone polite or not says no to you
because then rather than somebody who
seems more like oh yeah that sounds
great to you that's maybe not enough of
a challenge I don't look forward to it
it's not like I'm like oh please tell me
no but it's kind of like I don't know
it's you know it's a fire inside you you
tell me no and I'm like why do you want
to get in my way I'm gonna win you know
no matter what so I'm gonna make this
happen and you know and I have good
intentions with it I'm not I'm not
trying to defeat anybody but I have my
goals and my dreams and and and my
belief and it is is you know you can't
your belief in you and what you want to
do just can't waver it cannot and that's
the first place to work on if you don't
have that belief you need to work on it
and get it before you even take on the
beast of a feature or any dream you know
that you have
I'm sure curing cancer the people
working on right now they believe
they're gonna cure it no matter what and
you couldn't tell them you couldn't
convince them that they weren't gonna
cure it even though they haven't done it
yet but that's the kind of belief that
you need to have and determination to
accomplish your dreams no matter what
they are
you